Hi My Name Is Vir Das And I'm Gotta
Talk To You About My Favorite Videos I'm
A Comedian And Largely
Unemployed The First Video That I Like Is
Called Bulldog And Three Year Old Girl Is A
BFF I Should Explain I Have A Bulldog As His
Name  Is Doc Watson I'm a comedian
on the road all the time I want to be a
father some day I don't want to have a son I couldn't have a
daughter and I imagine in my mind that
my bulldog and my girl would be
BFFs and  Hope Fully By That Point
In Time The Word BFF Would Be Obsolete
And People Will Just Say Things Like
Friends That's More
Meaningful This Second Video Is By A Band
Called The American Authors And It's Called The
Best Day Of My
[Music]
Life They Did  A Video With A Bulldog I'm
Really Big Into Bulldog's Guys Add Drum So
Big And Loud I Jump So High I Didn't
Claw I Think I Was Jerky Bulldog
Rescues He Eats Like A Bulldog And He's
The Star Of The Video And It's Love Good To
Get  Into a Band and Then Don't Have a Band
In the Video If We Could Just Replace More
Bands with Dogs We Could Save the Music
Industry So What Napster Date Can Be Known
by
Dogs [
Music]
B Okay Third Video I Like Is Called Parrot
Dancing  Gangnam
Style Na Gangnam
Style Weave Now Moved From Bulldogs To
Birds Guys Buzz You Know I'm A Man With Range I Don't Just
Like One Thing I'm Into
Birds As Well That Sounds Much Creepier Than
Bulldogs And Three Year Old Girl But
Anyway So It  Is Like This Bad Ass Parrot And And Then He
Hears Music And Then He Does Like
A Head Bang Thing Which Nobody Does To Korean
Music Not Even Coreys This Pet I'm Way Ahead
Of
Time Thank You So Much For Watching Ga I Hope
You Enjoyed I I  i
group